[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était il ya 50 ans aujourd'hui trois
astronautes américains ont décollé pour
la première mission lunaire de
l'humanité après le rose comme sa tenue
en haleine des millions de gens devant
leur téléviseur car pour la première
fois il ya des hommes qui allaient
marcher sur la lune yves gingras
historien directeur scientifique de
l'observatoire des sciences et des
technologies de l'uqam peux nous en
parler bonjour bonjour on n'arrêtera pas
de parler de l'importance historique du
point de vue scientifique de cette de
cette mission le 2 sept
de cette aventure oui parce
qu'effectivement c'est la première fois
qu'une
une espèce parce qu'on parle de moi de
toutes les espèces qui sont sur la
famille l'espèce humaine qui se
distingue de tous les bonobos et de tous
les singes qu'on veut que congé lui les
choses qui ne lui permet de quitter la
terre et d'aller se promener quelques
instants sur la lune ce qui est donc cet
une chose du plan technologique
absolument extraordinaire c'est moins
une une découverte scientifique et
technologique conservait depuis newton
qu'on peut si on voit suffisamment vite
s'éloigner de la paire de quitter
l'orbité de la terre pour à les
installer dans un orbite autour de la
lune et ensuite sur les moyens
technologiques les fusées les appareils
d'atterrissage s'installer pour quelques
temps sur la lune qui vous rappelez ne
pas d'atmosphère donc on ne peut pas
vivre sur la lune il faut amener notre
oxygène il faut tout à mener donc c'est
purement un extraordinaire avancée
technologique cinquante ans plus tard
est ce qu'on ressent encore
l'influencent l'impact que ça pu avoir
sur les jeunes gens qui ont qui sont
devenus le ddd docteur en science et en
ingénierie
c'est sûr que aujourd'hui un jeune qui
veut aller en science et en technologie
et peut-être pas aussi influencé quelle
époque moi mon père m'a réveillé le
matin du 20 juillet que je regarde en
direct à la télé way l'appel les
premiers pas de neil armstrong sur la
lune ont aujourd'hui c'est très loin ce
qui est assez frais
à 50 ans distance c'est de voir le
déclin de la société américaine qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui 30 nous dit qu'il veut
retourner sur la lune dont vous voyez au
lieu d'aller vers quelque chose vers
l'avenir par des robots intelligents qui
peuvent aller marcher sur mars à des
robots on veut renvoyer des gens sur la
lune j'ai donc s'est retournée 50 ans en
arrière
oui il ya des gens qui faisait remarquer
que c'était vous avez fait allusion à la
technique 1 le défi technique que ça
représentait mais ce qu'on n'a pas su
remonter c'était le défi politique le
courage de continuer d'investir des
milliards dans cette recherche
oui parce que de 1960 et il faut quand
même rappeler que un polo c'est un
programme qui dévalisent d'apollo ans
jusqu'à port ou 20 or en 1970 ce alors
que après l'accident d'apollo 13 qui n'a
pas atterri sur la lune
le congrès américain a coupé des
milliards à la nasa quelques du sein
c'est les vols avec apollo 10 donc les
derniers astronautes qui sont atterri
sur la lune c'est sûr d'apollo 17 en
avant je crois ou en décembre 1972
donc les pauvres l'équipage d'apollo 18
et 19 qui est après bien des années à
l'avance aller sur la lune ont été déçus
par les coupures que le congrès
américain a mené on est proche de la
crise économique qui va arriver en 1973
il y aura plus jamais autant d'argent
que prévu pour aller sur la lune donc la
fed la lune c'est apollon 10 en quelques
secondes à 50 ans plus tard il ya encore
une bonne portion des quads et 3 182
kilos de roches rapporté qu'ils ont même
pas encore été observé au expliquer si
je comprends bien oui dont elle est la
science qui avançait de plus grâce aux
atterrissages sur la lune c'est bien sûr
la géologie des planètes on sait
maintenant l'âge de la lune on connaît
beaucoup mieux
son manque de formation et effectivement
les 380 kg peuvent servir aux géologues
pour étudier leurs compositions comparer
avec la composition on espère de la
planète masse et comparer aussi avec les
les les informations qu'on obtient
d'autres produits d'eau
autre objet planétaire ou qui ceux qui
se promènent les roches qu'on peut aller
observer par des robots mais l'avenir de
la conquête spatiale
à mon avis elle et via des robots et non
pas avec des humains bon on continuera à
suivre sa merci de nous avoir parlé ce
matin grande semaine qui s'annonce en
termes de célébrations et 2 et 2 à de
grands souvenirs scientifique merci
beaucoup d'appelés j